Deadpool please report to command.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Deadpool Marvel
trailer video Easter eggs and Deadpool 3
update everyone saw this trailer and
wondered why is Marvel doing a big
integration with Fortnight they did the
same thing for Avengers Infinity Ward
Avengers endgame with Thanos in the
Infinity Gauntlet to promote both of
those movies so what is Marvel's secret
plan and doing something this big right
now so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos we're doing an Amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
Deadpool Easter eggs on the video so
I'll explain what's going on with this
first why Marvel is doing this big
crossover because it is a big deal this
has been in the works for a long time
since after they got the rights back to
all the Fox Marvel characters which
includes Deadpool because he's
technically an x-men character everyone
remembers Thanos in the gauntlet the
reason they do stuff like this is just
because so much of the audience for
Marvel movies in that age range are the
same demographic of people playing video
games and Fortnight just happens to be
one of the most popular games in the
world so they market to that crowd
through the game creating more awareness
for the movies they had that really big
fort night joke and Avengers end game
with Thor Korg and meek yelling at noob
master
Thor he's back that kid on the TV just
called me a d*ckhead again. Noobmaster!
Wouldn't it be great if Deadpool was eventually
revealed as new master once Ryan
Reynolds makes his official MCU debut if
you don't play fortnight though what
happened is is there's a new Deadpool
part of the game that you have to unlock
yet to find Deadpool in an underground
bunker that's why this trailer is
basically him in an underground bunker
hiding out but when you eventually find
one of his bunkers you find that there's
Avengers MCU graffiti all over the place
so it's just tying it back around to
Avengers end game and Deadpool now being
part of the MCU
technically part of the MCU Deadpool 3
is one of those weird movies that's
going to be rated R and technically he's an
MCU character but because it's going to be
so crazy they're probably going to release
Deadpool 3 through their Fox label so
they'll be like a weird Marvel logo at
the beginning of the movie instead of
doing the traditional MCU logo usually
big integrations like this between
Marvel and video game companies
arrange a long time in advance because
of all the contracts the money that has
to change hands and the requirements for
how the game companies get to use the
characters so this Deadpool crossover
has been in the works for the past year
or so since the Fox Disney deal finished
closing Marvel knew at the time that it
was going to be a couple years before
they could figure out how to make
Deadpool 3 and what the story would be
how it would fit in the MCU so Marvel
probably wanted this event just to hype
up the Deadpool character to keep him in
the larger public consciousness just to
keep people tied over yes we're making a
Deadpool movie but it's going to be a while
before you see it we don't want you to
forget about the character until then
that's why Ryan Reynolds has been
posting so much extra new Deadpool 3
stuff on his social media accounts since
the Fox Disney deal went through because
it's going to take him a couple years to
figure out Deadpool 3 within this
trailer there are a bunch of specific
Deadpool Easter eggs like Deadpool
making fun of the virus quarantine and
the fact that the toilet paper has
recently become an endangered species so
he has to use the fortnight magazine as
toilet paper
the slurp soda and the back is just a
reference to the slurp juice inside the
game which gives you more health the
banana on the cover that reads banana of
the year just peel e the banana who was
a big game mechanic from last year if
you play the game he spawns in specific
locations and bunkers around the island
you have to track him down
using these computer terminals but the
benefit of unlocking Deadpool in the
game once you complete all these
challenges is that you just get to walk
around in the Deadpool costume so it's
basically a couple of new Deadpool skins
this is a Deadpool party yacht there's a
Deadpool battle bus there's even another
reference to the Fox Disney deal from
last year where Deadpool writes a letter
to Epic Games trolling them about
betting his friend that they wouldn't
put him in the game so for about the
past year since the deal went through
obviously it's going to take him a while to
figure out Deadpool 3 but they've just
been hyping up Deadpool inside the MCU
using all these big game integrations
Ryan Reynolds on his social media
accounts this way right after the deal
went through around Avengers end game
hitting theaters last year Ryan Reynolds
posted this Deadpool 3 teaser the leak
of ursery the anniversary of the date
that Ryan Reynolds himself leaked the
Deadpool test footage at Comic Con that
year
we have no idea how that happened but I
promise you I'm looking into it but
here's my top 5 Deadpool stories that
they could use for Deadpool 3 that would
explain how he fits in the MCU while
still keeping the movie rated our number
5 the good the bad and the ugly from
Deadpool vol 3 during this story
Deadpool keeps waking up every morning
finding out that someone has been
stealing his internal organs but because
he can regenerate himself he just shrugs
it off like it's no big deal he then
finds out that someone has been stealing
his internal organs and using them to
try and recreate new weapons as part of
the weapons Plus program he goes to
Wolverine and Captain America to get
help in stopping them Captain America
himself gets captured because he's also
part of the super soldier weapons Plus
program Marvel even made an official
animated version of the story a couple
of years ago now obviously we have old
Captain America in the MCU right now and
Chris Evans isn't going to show up
inside a Deadpool movie whoever winds up
being the new version of Wolverine
probably isn't going to debut till some
other x-men movie during Marvel phase 5
for Deadpool Ronan this is a story like
Marvel 1602 and Elseworlds story set in
the distant past of Japan and alternate
versions of all the Marvel characters so
you have deadpool running around ancient
japan trying to kill a bunch of people
you do the movie as an else world story
set in a fictional past with alternate
versions of the characters then at the
end of the movie Deadpool could wake up
in present day inside a mental
institution in the main MCU universe
Wizard of Oz style revealing that he
hallucinate adult thing number three
Deadpool Strange Days big multiverse
Doctor Strange story Vanessa gets
kidnapped by an alternate version of
Deadpool from another universe and
Deadpool has to break into the sanctum
sanctorum in his universe and steal
magical artifacts from Doctor Strange in
order to get her back and kill the
Deadpool that took her in instead of
having a big Benedict Cumberbatch
crossover a cameo and doing full blown
Deadpool vs. Doctor Strange team-up
because that's not very realistic you
just have some funny moments of Deadpool
trying to survive all the intelligent
magical artifacts inside the sanctum
like Deadpool messing around inside the
x-mansion breaking stuff during Deadpool
2 they did the exact same thing with the
Thor character during the thor ragnarok
Doctor Strange crossover scenes with
this time you just have funny moments
like deadpool fighting the cloak of
levitation and then once he gets what he
needs to save vanessa he uses a portal
to get to her wearing the cloak of
levitation briefly before it returns to
the sanctum then when he tries to come
back he pulls a Rick and Morty and just
completely destroys everything falls
through a different portal Alice in
Wonderland style and winds up in the
main MCU universe when the main sanctum
right in front of Wang who just makes a
joke and they slam to the credits number
two doing Deadpool three in the same
style as they're doing a spider-man vs.
venom crossover with Tom Hollands
spider-man in the sonne venom verse the
way they're doing spider-man venom
crossover is that venom isn't going to
be some alternate dimension they're just
going to pretend like he's in the MCU
without referencing a lot of MCU stuff
so when Deadpool 3 you just have
deadpool fighting some x-men villains
like mr. sinister or the Hellfire Club
and it takes place in the MCU but they
only joke about the other Avengers MCU
characters you never see any of them on
screen in number one probably the most
infamous Deadpool Elseworlds story
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe for
Deadpool 3 within that comic book
Deadpool goes crazy learns that he's a
fictional character in a comic book and
then goes around killing all the Marvel
characters both heroes villains x-men
Avengers alike but you do this is
another Wizard of Oz style twist where
Deadpool wakes up in a mental
institution after it's all over inside
the main MC you having hallucinate 'add
fighting all the Avengers characters
where am I really so just to be clear
when Deadpool shows up in other MCU
movies like if he shows up in an
Avengers movie like Avengers 5 that
would be a pg-13 version of Deadpool
like you see during Once Upon a Deadpool
all the main Deadpool spin-off movies
like Deadpool 3 those are going to be
rated R which means that they have to be
kind of careful about the way they
market them and cross them over with the
other MCU characters but those movies
will probably be released through the
Fox label they probably won't wind up on
Disney Plus unless they do a special
pg-13 cut of Deadpool 3 just like they
did for Deadpool 2 but everyone let me
know in the comments what do you want
them to do for the story of Deadpool 3
now that they can reference anything
that they
within the MCU and technically he is an
MCU character right now it looks like
Deadpool 3 probably won't be released
till 2022 or 2023 firmly in Marvel phase
5 but if we get any more details about
what's going on or Marvel drops any more
promos or big integrations I'll totally
do Easter Egg videos for it if you
didn't see I'm also doing an MCU
rewatched video series where i rewatch
all the MCU infinity saga movies doing
new breakdowns and Marvel phase 4
connections and Easter eggs that we
didn't spot the first time I just posted
my first video for that it's the first
Iron Man movie click here for that video
everyone click here for the really big
Thor 4 teaser the Taika Waititi dropped
the other day thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!